die körperteile
mit quiz
der körper
die körper
der kopf
die köpfe
die kopfschmerzen
ich habe solche kopfschmerz
ein
ich habe solche kopfschmerzen
woher kommen die nur
[Musik]
die haare
ich habe braune haare
ich habe brown
meine haare
[Musik]
schwarze haare
meine haare sind blond
meine grünen haare passen zu meinen
augen
die stirn
die augenbraue
die augenbrauen
die augen
uhr
die augenbrauen
du solltest dir wirklich mal die
augenbrauen zupfen
die wimpern
das auge
die augen
meine augen sind grün
meine augen
sind grün
meine augen sind blau
meine augen sind braun
die nase
die nasen
ich habe eine stupsnase
[Musik]
ich habe
eine stupsnase
[Musik]
ich habe eine breite nase
ich
eine breite nase
ich habe
eine clown nase
meine nase läuft schon
wieder
meinen
er läuft schon wieder
[Musik]
ich glaube ich habe mich erkältet
das ohr
die ohren
die wangen
der mund
die lippen
der zahn
die zähne
apa
ich habe solche zahn
herzen
ich habe solche zahnschmerzen
ich muss
zum zahnarzt
ich muss dringend zum zahnarzt
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
ich glaube ich habe ein
loch im zahn
ich glaube
ich habe ein loch im zahn
lassen sie mich doch mal sehen
öffnen sie bitte ihren mund
oh ja ich sehe das problem
das sieht nicht gut aus
dieser zahn muss sofort raus
dieses problem ist gelöst
sie waren sehr tapfer
das kinn
der hals
der nacken
aua
woher kommen plötzlich diesen
kind schmerzen
woher kommen
schlicht diesen nackenschmerzen
ich glaube ich habe mir ein
nerv eingeklemmt
ich glaube ich habe mir einen nerv
eingeklemmt
das sieht aber gar nicht gut aus
damit solltest du besser zu einem arzt
gehen
der oberkörper
die post
ab morgen gehe ich ins fitness
studio
ab morgen gehe ich ins fitnessstudio
mit dieser show
gegen brust ist jetzt schluss
mit dieser
ich muss noch härter trainieren
das harte training
hat sich gelohnt
das harte training hat sich gelohnt
nur
köse brust an
nur meine muskulöse brust an
der bauch
der bauchnabel
die schulter
die schultern
der oberarm
der ellbogen
der unterarm
das handgelenk
die hand
die hände
habt ihr eure hände gewaschen
die hände sind ja immer noch schmutzig
geht und was euch die hände
der daumen
der zeigefinger
der mittelfinger
der ringfinger
der kleine finger
der fingernagel
der unterkörper
die hüfte
der oberschenkel
das knie
der unterschenkel
das fußgelenk
der fuß
die füße
die 10
herzlich willkommen zu unserem körper
quiz
versuche zu jeder aussage die passende
antwort zu finden
ich wünsche dir viel erfolg
wenn uns jemand ruft könnten wir ohne
sie nicht hören
du hast es bestimmt schon richtig
erraten
die richtige antwort lautet
die ohren
wenn wir zu viel essen um keinen sport
treiben wird er zu dick
[Musik]
der bauch
sie sind auf dem kopf und haben
verschiedene farben
[Musik]
die antwort ist
die haare
wenn wir lesen oder etwas ansehen
allen brauchen wir sie
wenn wir lesen oder etwas ansehen wollen
brauchen wir sie
[Musik]
hast du es erraten
korrekt es sind die augen
wir müssen unsere nahrung mit ihnen
zerkleinern
[Musik]
bereit für die antwort
das körperteil nachdem wir suchen lautet
die zähne
wow das sind aber schöne beißerchen
sie sind der längste teil unseres
körpers
[Musik]
die beine
ich bitte um entschuldigung
das bein
boxer verwenden sie zum sport
andere leute benutzen sie zum streiten
[Musik]
die fäuste
gut gemacht opa
sie sind am ende der beine und wir gehen
und laufen damit
[Musik]
die richtige antwort lautet
die füße
sie hängen von den schultern und am ende
sind die hände
[Musik]
du hast es bestimmt erraten
die arme
ohne sie könnte man den duft einer blume
nicht riechen
[Musik]
die nase
ohne ihn würden wir nicht existieren
weil das wichtigste organ darin ist
[Musik]
die lösung lautet
der kopf
bist du bereit für das letzte rätsel
wenn wir in der nase bohren oder auch
etwas zeigen wollen verwenden wir sie
wenn wir in der
sie bohren oder auch etwas zeigen wollen
verwenden wir sie
[Musik]
es ist nicht die nase die hatten wir
schon
die lösung lautet
die oder der finger
wie viele antworten hast du richtig
erraten schreibe es in die kommentare
[Musik]
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video